hey everybody its Jesse and uh if you
saw the description for this video it's
very vague because today as you can see
I have my to-do list up and I just need
to get through some of this stuff
normally I try to pick out something
that I haven't done before or that I
think might be interesting and I I do
that during my streaming time but
there's really not much left on the
to-do list that I think is really that
interesting the link to this Trello
board is in the description you can
check it out if you see something in one
of these three columns that hasn't been
done yet that sounds really interesting
let me know in the live chat or even in
the comments to the video if I if you
comment if you're watching the recording
and you comment before I'm done with
this site then maybe I could do it but
for now I've just been working on some
of these didn't get to do as much as I
had hoped today because I had some
meetings this morning and can't I always
don't like when I have a lot of meetings
because it just feels like I don't get
anything done
I'm sure the important stuff does get
done in meetings but you just can't see
it I'm going to check the live chat here
before we get into any code everybody a
lot of people saying how handle a chat
all right Peter says usually joins in
about an hour after the stream starts
but this time he is early so awesome
okay uh okay Jayden asks what are you
doing now alright so I'll show you what
I was just working on right before this
stream started so basically I was
working on this ad adding images to the
resource section so we I think I stream
some
of this before I mean we've definitely
streamed a lot from that section that
resource page we're doing a lot on there
so let me show you what I've done and
I'm on if you're following the the
github repo I'm on the branch for called
resource images so this stuff isn't in
the master branch yet it's not live yet
but basically I just pulled in these
images and everything's working like I
wanted it to I'll show you how I did
this in a second but what I was doing
was I was checking the width of the
image and if the image width was less
than 600 pixels then I was not
displaying it because at some point I
think when you get down to like here
then this image is almost 600 pixels
there so I need it to look good at some
point it would be nice to optimize it
even further maybe and use some
responsive images but that's not really
necessary at this point at least you
know it's more important just to get the
images up at this point than to really
be nitpicky about the speed but here's
the problem when I scroll down here
these images are I mean these don't look
like they're 600 pixel images they look
all stretched out so and especially if
you zoom in like you can really tell so
somebody is looking at this on the small
screen like this let me scroll down here
I mean look that's just not that doesn't
look good now this is what I was trying
to avoid by setting that that limit or
that minimum width so I'm waiting on
some information back from the person
who uploads the images so what I'm
thinking I'm up basically when I go to
look at the at the data I'm getting from
WordPress which I'll show you here what
I'm getting if there is an image it
shows up like this so a better featured
image and it has it gives me the width
of the original image
so all of these images are showing that
the original image has this width of at
least 600 pixels and then when I go to
let me show you the one that that I just
showed you that's not really great
quality so this link should it this will
take me to the image the full image
that's supposed to be 666 pixels wide
okay look that's definitely you know a
wide image but that's not quality so
what what I think happened maybe is that
when I had sent an email saying you know
if you're going to upload pictures make
sure there's 600 pixels wide at least
where they're not going to show up so
what I think happened is they resize the
images so they took the small images and
just resize them to 600 pixels and then
uploaded them which of course is not
it's going to look like this so I'm
waiting for confirmation
back that that is in fact what happened
and if that's the case I'll just have to
provide clear instructions that we don't
want the images resize as soon as I hear
back from that one way or the other then
I can merge this with the master branch
and I can make it live I'm not like
thrilled how this looks so I don't know
maybe I'll take I won't include these
images unless I haven't alt for all of
these I don't know what do you think to
me like this this just looks really
weird that you know this is very small
and these are now huge also I'm not sure
about when I go down you know to like
this size this would be more like
somebody on their phone I don't even
know if I want to have images on this
side this is ends up being a really long
scroll I mean oh there's only a few
images but if you can imagine like what
if most of these had images you'd be
scrolling forever I'm thinking it maybe
just not doing any images for small
screens load
we'll be much better which is great
because if you're on your mobile and
you're on your data plan you don't want
to load a bunch of images anyway so let
me know what you think about that I'm
still undecided as of yet so your input
would be very much appreciated all right
so I'm just going to switch to another
branch should work on something else
until I hear back so I don't even know
if all your back today or if it'll be
until next week so I would I kind of
hopes that I could get this going you
get this live today but we'll see I'm I
definitely don't want it to be live with
those images looking like that so trying
to find my console here so I'm thinking
about just switching back I move this
into like the testing area just so that
I know it's basically done I'm just
waiting on on some info here I was
thinking about going back to that search
bar so we got this working and remember
there are just a few optimizations that
I wanted to make and I didn't do any
styling on the search bar at all so it
definitely it doesn't look like I want
it to look so it's thinking about
switching back to this branch and just
doing that so if there's any objections
to going back and finishing up with this
search page let me know I know we did
spend a while on that before so if
you're tired of that tell me maybe I can
find something else to do I just looks
like I got a bunch of stuff in the live
stream so I'm going to check the live
stream now really quickly just to see if
you have some feedback for me before we
start okay so uh as our says it's Fabian
here today to save Jessie and yeah in
case you haven't seen the past few
streams Fabian and I'm not even sure if
I'm pronouncing your name right Fagin so
if you hear this let me know because
he's from Paris so maybe it's more like
Fabien or something like that I don't
really know he did save me he submitted
a pull request and it was just awesome
and his way to deal with the problem I
was dealing with was way better than my
way and it worked and and then he
actually joined in the next day in the
stream and and basically step by step
like coached me through how to get the
search function to work so super helpful
but I don't know if he's here today he
hasn't said anything in the live chat so
we'll see hopefully is here and a lot of
the stuff I'm when we doing today isn't
like super difficult stuff so I don't
think I'll get stuck to the point where
I'm just I'm totally lost
Mamadou says hello what is it about this
live I'm not sure I'm not sure what
you're asking so if you can clarify that
for me that would be great now I'll try
to answer
okay Roland says you put images on the
left or right side just color the car
the color of the image Philly says why
not make the images only appear when you
hover the mouse okay as possible you
should have hyperlinks for the images
David's issue shut up your legs
Roland thinks it would be too abrupt to
add the hover Othon ace had made a few
fixes for FES marcom okay so we got
another pool request I will check that
out I'll check that out after the stream
let me know what what parts of the site
are they fixes for because if you could
just quickly let me know in the live
stream that way I won't try to mess with
them right now and I you know do the
work that you've just done but I really
appreciate that and I will check that
out as soon as I'm done
Oh John says use flex justify to stretch
justify content stretch to fill the
heights and then change of media queries
I have I actually was doing something
like that before I wasn't using flex
because the way that I have the cards
now in the columns it um it didn't work
ray basically like I why I should say it
it was easier I'm not it's not for me to
describe that I did it basically I did
something very similar to that
John's suggestion was to you know like
fill the heights make them the same
height so I might go back to that if I
I'll see I'll play with some stuff they
said but I'm not going to mess with it
anymore until I am until I hear back
about what's going on with those images
alright thanks man I figured you added a
description in the pool request Vinay
says he had a description I just wanted
like just like a very quick what are
they about because I didn't want to like
go over the the request during the live
stream
Wow okay awesome
Vinay it seems like he did a lot of
stuff I'm definitely going to check that
out please
wha-wha Hodge says please add some black
UI where you want to add the black UI
andreas asked about the Trello Powler
power up oh yeah
the Trello power up is I added it so
long ago I don't even remember what it
was let's see what I have activated um
it's not even why is it not showing up
you know what maybe it's not a power
maybe it's um
this might be a browser plug-in see
Burrard it's called burn down for Trello
and I think it's actually a browser
plug-in and not a not a power up in
Trello so I'm using the free version
that works for me
a full version lets you do cool stuff
with charts like burn down charts and
things alright so let me get to work I'm
going to do this there are no objections
that I saw to working on the search so
I'm going to go to that that's probably
is the most like technically challenging
thing on the list right now so maybe
that would be more appealing to everyone
especially for those of you who are a
little bit more advanced it would be
more appealing some of this other stuff
is just really basic so let me switch to
that branch
there we go GlassFish okay so switch to
the live search branch I always get
weird
I said not always I often get an error
when I switch to try to switch branches
there we go and I just need to manually
refresh it's something with a hot module
reloading messes up when I switch so so
we got the resources page here's our
search bar in case you didn't see when
we made this search bar basically as
soon as we search for anything we have
like a live search let me search for
something that's legit okay so we have
you know this actually is I've typed in
the first part of this name so it
actually shows up there and then not
only that if I clicked on these it would
keep whatever I searched for and then I
could sort by these same categories so
it keeps all the sorting I thought I
added a min height maybe I just talked
about adding him in height and didn't do
it I think I did add it to Trello though
so actually that's a good one to start
with which I can at least get something
checked off the list let me see you see
if I added this
I guess I didn't I didn't even have it
to Trello so I probably just forgot
about it completely maybe that was one
of the days where I had to leave like
immediately or go to a meeting
immediately after the stream there was
one stream where I really pushed it and
I ended the stream at like 259 and I had
a meeting at 3:00 and I just run over
alright so basically I want to add
here's what I want to do and this is
easy I don't like that when I type
something in and there's nothing it just
totally shrinks up like this so I'm
going to add an in height I did if I
remember some other suggestions about
animating this transitions but for now
I'm just going to add them in height
because as I mentioned before in an
earlier project it's getting to the
point where I just like I need to be
done I think people you know higher up
than me my bosses and their bosses are
thinking like you know why is this
project you're egging on they haven't
said it like that but that's the feeling
that I'm getting so I need to just
finish it up and I don't want to spend
like 13 hours a day like I was doing
trying to get this finished so I gotta
just be I got is you some judgment on
which what's really necessary and what's
just kind of more nitpicky to do so let
me go to the code here I'm at resources
and I am using next also I'm not not
watching the live chat like really
diligently right now so I'm going to be
going back and forth but I'd like to
maybe complete a task and then go back
to the chat and just go back and forth
like that for maybe like an hour 45
minutes and then I'll go back to the
chat and only answer questions let's see
actually yet today as I'm looking for
this I'm going to fill you in on some of
the some of the stuff that's been
happening here since this show is about
just the day-to-day job that I'm doing
a front-end developer so I like to fill
you in on some of the other stuff that
happens when I'm not live-streaming just
to give you a better picture of what my
job is like I don't really know if this
is my job is a good example what
front-end developers jobs are normally
like or not I work at a university so I
imagine a lot of universities do need
developers for their sites so in that
sense it's maybe like that but probably
not like a tech company would have I
think this is the column the row that we
need actually need more than the row I
like this section to have a so if you
haven't worked with react before this is
going to freak you out to put the CSS
right here but I'm going to do it here I
could also put it here okay so I have
been using this you know style JSX tag
and I can write the CSS just like
regular CSS in here but if I'm going to
do something to just one element I
usually just put an inline I there's
there's no point in me just going it
down here if it's only applying to one
element at least that's that's the way I
feel it's easier for me to see
immediately what's happening because
it's right here I don't have to like
look at the class and then go down here
and figure it out so I'm sure there are
other opinions and pros and cons to
doing it a different way but I'm going
to do it so I can just type in style and
I'm explaining this in case you know
there might be some people watching that
aren't familiar at all with with react
or anything so I'm kind of explaining
some things that I know I've explained
before might be so basic to some some of
you here more advanced they're just
going to bear with me all right so we're
going to go style and we're going to
start with our brackets here and these
curly brackets mean in a react component
this means that we're going to write
some JavaScript we're telling react like
hey expect JavaScript now and then
inside of that I have more curly
brackets so since we're in JavaScript
land inside of here this simply means
hey this is an object right that's
normal you know you put the curly
brackets
so when you want to write CSS in your
component you do it at least in next you
do it like this I'm not sure if it's
like this by default for reacts or this
is the next thing let me know because I
haven't done a lot with react when I'm
not using next with it as well I've
tried some stuff but webpack just
crushed me the first time I tried it so
I didn't really get very far so I want
to go min height oops
when you're doing it in here you can
camelcase it so pretty much all pretty
much every see I haven't run into any
CSS attributes that I couldn't camelcase
and make it work just in case you don't
want to camelcase you don't like that I
could put this in quotes and just use it
like normally but I think the camel case
is fun once you get used to it it's it's
alright but I can understand if you're
going back and forth between regular CSS
and this it could be confusing you might
want to just stick to it
now the second property you usually want
to plug quotes around it I'm not sure
you may be able to get away with putting
the number like just a straight number
value without quotes but I just always
use the quotes no matter what even if I
don't have to I'm going to give this
maybe 500 pixels and just see I kind of
feel like we already played with this a
little bit and then I just forgot the
value that we settled on but we'll try
500 pixels at first and this will just
be a nice demonstration see so not
nearly the same type of jarring
transition could probably get away with
doing a little bit higher but I'm
alright with that oh you know what we
need to make one more change and we made
this last time and see this is a good
example of when you make it change like
in dev tools and then you put it off
actually coding it then you have to do
it all over again
what happened here on maybe a few days
ago we did a video and I made all these
changes but I only did them in dev tools
and then I didn't code them so at least
it's I remember what I had to do but
this could have been a lot of wasted
effort if I didn't go back to this for a
couple of weeks and just totally forgot
so basically I'm vertically aligning
whatever's in this container
and I'm using my the framework that I'm
using for the UI is materialized the
material design framework and it has
this nice class here with these two
classes the V align wrapper and then via
line and then anything in this container
is vertically aligned so that's really
nice that's cool because it's based on
flex so browsers don't support Franck
flex it won't work with so like if you
view the site right now in Internet
Explorer 11 none of the vertical line
works everything just goes right to the
top but I'm not super worried about
supporting Internet Explorer 11 right
now based on the analytics that we have
for a lot of our other sites we have
very few visits from people using
Internet Explorer 11 so it's not really
worth it's not a good use of my time to
optimize anything for Internet Explorer
at this point so that should fix it so
if we go back yep now everything's at
the top it'll stay at the top we don't
get there you go very nice and at least
much nicer than before I think it was I
think Rohan gave the suggestion to
animate this and I think I mentioned
before but I think that's an awesome
suggestion but I said I'm that's kind of
nitpicky I'm not sure how many people
even you know be upset about that that
transition so if I do get time I would
definitely put it in if not it won't
make it
although rhoann if you really want to
you can submit a pull request to do that
I don't expect you know
anybody to take their time do it to work
on this for me but if you want to then I
really appreciate it so the next thing
we need to do is figure out how we want
this to look right now I have it taking
up half but I wanted to my idea was I
was going to have a drop down as well so
there would be a search and then there'd
be drop down and the drop down would
have like basically the equivalent of
what the tags would be normally like in
a blog like in a wordpress blog you have
categories and tags since we have these
already and these basically act is like
the broad categories that's okay I mean
that works but I the people that I'm
making the site for had in mind kind of
a drop-down with some more some
categories that were focused on the
content so these are the type of content
but something that was focused more on
the the content itself like you know
what what the topic is so I don't know
that I'm going to add that in right now
number one reason basically being we
have not decided on what the topic
should be so I'm not putting in a
drop-down if there's nothing to go in
the drop-down and I don't really want to
go through right now and try to pick out
topics that's I don't think that's
really it's not really what I should be
doing I think someone else more familiar
with all of this content could do a
better job than I can so I'm going to
wait on that I'll probably let I'll let
somebody else know about it and at that
point maybe I can add this I kind of
want to see what this would look like if
it was all the way across I think it
might look weird on a wider screen I
don't know what do you think would it be
better to put it all the way across that
that will look fine on a smaller screen
maybe all right here's my idea right now
let me know what you think on a large
screen it's
just going to go halfway like this on a
small screen is going to be all the way
across also is this is this clear enough
that you can search here or do you think
this needs do I need an icon should I
throw in a little search icon in here or
the word search a plain enough here also
I definitely need to change this color
this is the default color that I've
added I have like kind of a little
starter theme just for styles that I use
for all my projects and the this is one
of the university's official colors but
this site doesn't use university colors
because it's us like a separate it's
part of university but it's kind of a
separate undertaking in some ways so
they get to use a different color
palette all right I'm going to check the
live chat really quick to see what you
all think about this before I make any
changes
okay so mom mama mama do it's ma ma do
you I'm not sure how to pronounce that
please let me know how to pronounce that
so I can do it right I don't I don't
want to keep mispronouncing it if I am
it clarified the earlier question he
says I mean what is he coding for so I'm
coding for I work at a university so I'm
coding a website for one of the
endeavors of the university it's kind of
like a new Department thing that they've
started they've there they have this
other company that's creating a learning
management system from scratch based on
Drupal for people to be able to get like
certifications so they're not going to
get a full degree but they can get a
certification through this online
learning management system that they're
building the website that I'm coding is
kind of like the marketing informational
site that people can go to before
they're directed to the actual learning
management system and at that point they
can sign up for an account and pay for
it and do courses and stuff so that's
that's what I'm coding right now SR says
I think you should now start coding
you're getting late
I agree Thanks thanks for the reminder
if you've watched any of my shows you
know I can talk a little bit and not
code wash has change your navbar on top
uh it look it looks really old um you
mean like this navbar like the sticky
nav it's kind of floating here is that
or like the whole one the whole thing
here I'm not going to disagree with you
about certain design elements this site
is a mix of design elements that we're
in a site that was built previous to
this or these partially built and some
design elements that I added so I will
say not all the design decisions on this
site were from me
I did have to compromise on a lot of
things so but if you have suggestions
and I can change them I will change them
but I am NOT I don't have the freedom to
change the design to whatever I want at
least not without having more meetings
and discussion so but I'm definitely
interested in and like lodge and maybe
you explaining more what you mean and
how I could change it rested us which
framework are you using for that
it's materialized is the the like CSS
jazz framework and I'm using react but
particularly XJS to like scaffold to
react AB Patrick's is in there supposed
to be a visual representation with pager
on in the nav bar it doesn't seem like
it is working um actually no I didn't
build that in the visual representation
it is on my list though or at least I I
remember it being maybe right now it's
not like that I could make it like that
and maybe I should Mayer should put that
on the list that would be helpful so
maybe that will go on the list I don't
know if that'll be my boss is kind of
reviewing my list right now to see like
what things actually need to get done
and what can kind of just be left left
off so I don't know if that'll make it
onto what needs to be done but that's
probably a good idea
in regard to the case for the CSS like
that I was talking about here when I was
putting it in line and react Patrick
says the react way to do it is camelcase
okay alright rhoann says he he'll do the
pull request so awesome thank you and
don't don't feel like you have to do it
tomorrow if you if you don't get to it
that's fine I mean you're you don't have
to do it at all if you don't want to
bill says I think the search icon would
be a good idea awesome bill bill
actually sent me a link to a site he's
going with next as well and it's awesome
I was really impressed with the code
bill I like how you were like you were
making API calls in your server das file
like where I was doing it in the in the
component like in the page in the get
initial props you're doing it on the
server I was really kind of checking
that out I'd like to know you don't have
to answer me now you could message me on
Twitter but I'd like to know your
reasoning behind that what's the benefit
of doing it like that and also how does
that work like let's say if you were
going to do a live search thing like
this where all these calls to the API
are being made like within the component
like on the client side how would that
work what I have is there any way to do
this differently I don't know I just
kind of want your thoughts on that
because I'm really intrigued by it and I
like the idea of using the the URL to
the WordPress back and making that an
environment variable and kind of like
hiding it I don't really need to hide it
for most of my sites but if I ever did
I'm going to keep that in mind
everybody's saying seems like everybody
saying go for the icon so let's go with
the icon John saying also maybe a box
shadow underneath the line
okay Rowan's sang sticky nav could be a
bit bigger it looks kind of weird okay
and let's see
robot Villa says the UX guideline text
text plus icon enhances usability
alright thanks for that you're right you
are right about that I will add that
and John says 75% length might would
look better alright so let me let me
just some of the suggestions here let's
do it so for sure we need to add a
search icon
okay everybody is on board with that
we've had a suggestion to make this 75%
instead of half and then also a slightly
unrelated suggestion was make the text
in the white background section to be
aligned Center
all right actually I will say this there
was quite a controversy over how to
align these sections so I'm not going to
mess with the alignment of this right
now just because there there was finally
consensus among all the people involved
in the project of and then the
conclusion ends up being the home page
the first section on the home page will
be Center on and on every other page it
will be left aligned and everything will
be left aligned so that's one of those
decisions that I'm not going to revisit
I'm just going to leave it as it is at
this point because there was there are
so many opinions about it but I
appreciate Thea saying that all right so
let me throw in an icon here I am I'm
loading I think I'm loading the material
icons but I'd rather use an inline SVG
icon I like using those better and then
that way I can just not load the rest of
the material design icons and use just
the ones I want so I'm going to do it
like that
and I think I use this in a project
recently trying to remember what project
it is so I can just grab the code it'll
probably be faster for me to just get it
so let's go to material tear icons what
I'm going to do is I'm actually just
going to grab the code from the SVG so
like the SVG tag and I'm going to stick
it right in there if anybody knows of a
reason why that's not a good idea
no I've been doing it on a lot of sites
lately I haven't had any issues with
like browsers not being able to display
that but if there is some issue that I
just haven't figured out yet you know
about it please let me know the
alternative would be loading like font a
font icon set and just look using the
phone icon so usually I just go here the
material icons I select SVG and it
downloads it looks like I've already
downloaded this but I'll do it again
because it's just going to be faster and
then I open it I would rather it not
open in the browser because then I don't
have to view the source but this gives
me a nice SVG I know that super small
it'll get bigger when I paste it in so
that gives me a nice SVG tag and I can
put it in here so I can put it directly
in here in the label and we'll see it in
a second it'll need some extra styling
but at least you see actually it's
probably not is it going to work I may
have to change some of the fill high a
few looks with maybe not off to see
sometimes you have to change the B
attributes because they don't work in
react like as you would normally use
them so we'll see if it alright it
worked I'm not getting I would have
gotten like the pink screen with an
error if it didn't work so I just could
not remember hmm
obviously I'm going to change the color
of this is going to be more gray but
what do you think about the entire
search icon going up like that I don't
know that I like that I don't even know
that I like it right here would it be
better on the end I mean this obviously
is the easiest way to do it let me know
I'm going to change the length of this
while I give you all a chance to lay in
on where you think this should go
in materialise they have this this
column classes similar to bootstrap or
other frameworks so I'm just going to
give this a column class of let's see
nine and that'll get me that 75% but I
also want to I want to do that on medium
screens and on a small screen I want to
do twelve so you can see it's pretty
easy to handle columns such a small
screen it's a twelve column layout so
twelve means full width and then
obviously for twelve columns
three-fourths of twelve columns 75% is
nine so we should see there we go okay
so now we have that 75% length here let
me know what you will think about that
if that's okay and when we get to it
should be 600 pixels or less yet then we
get it all the way across so not bad
actually you know what I want to test
and I totally forgot about this right
now we're searching on key up but will
that work on mobile let me know if you
dealt with this before I do key up
events even fire on mobile like on that
virtual keyboard or not I mean I'll be
able to test it and find out so it's
it's not a big deal with if you don't
know you know but if you happen to be on
your phone or have your phone on you and
would like to test actually you can
because this isn't live yet so I'm at
I'll have to wait and test it or at
least just look it up all right so the
the delay on the video is probably it's
probably been enough time that you've
heard my question about this so I'm
going to check the live chat
okay so rhoann says the phone icon is
usually too big and not worth it for
just one icon yeah I agree that why load
all those icons if you just need a few
of them that's why I'm using its SVG's
I've also had issues with certain
browsers not displaying my font icons
especially when I've used font awesome
four icons I don't know if any of you
have had the issue the same issue but
occasionally I actually had somebody
look at one of my sites and left some
really nasty messages on the
University's Facebook page that there
was a post that was linking to the
particular site I did and was like super
upset that the font icons wouldn't work
claiming that we didn't know what we
were doing which I don't know maybe I
didn't know what I was doing but it had
worked on all the other browsers I've
tested so anyway I've decided to kind of
get away from using full font icon sets
and just using SVG's because I've had
more luck with SVG's working john
recommends making sure the SVG code is
simplified and clean yeah definitely I
don't need all that stuff in the SVG so
that might be worthwhile to just do on
the live stream in case somebody hasn't
worked with SVG so let me see which ones
I don't think I need this I'm just going
to pull stuff out and see if it breaks
because that's that makes for a good
educational experience right
yep see okay that works so we don't need
that this SVG is already actually really
small so you know it's not like I'm
saving that much but there are some
SVG's they're huge and have all kind of
extra stuff they're not aren't needed so
it's definitely worthwhile to shrink
them down so do I need filled and I
don't think I need this either let's
take that out and see see what happens
oops I keep
oh I guess I do need that so all right
I'm not sure if I can take like I could
take some of these out and just use CSS
to put them in but I mean that's I'm
going I'm using inline CSS anyway so I
don't really see the point in taking
this out and then just writing style and
putting it back in and style so I will
change this to be the same color as the
text so I might as well do that right
now let's see what color I'm using for
this text the inspect thing just opened
on my my other screen so if you're
wondering where that's at but all I'm
doing really is just grabbing the color
actually I don't I don't like how that
colors done let me show you what's going
on the color here is like a hex value
for gray I don't like that I in if you
look at the material design
documentation they recommend never using
just gray for text they recommend using
black but having it be slightly
transparent so I'll show you so instead
of that gray like let's just do black
right so we've done black and then we'll
go in and let's let's set it to actually
this will this should do it guys will
set it to like I think 57 is one of the
values that they recommend so I'm just
going to set it to 57 right so now the
Texas like this the reason that they
recommend doing that is that it becomes
much more readable so I wish I had a
side by side of like both text that I
don't but you have to take my word for
it right now or at least take Google's
word for it right now it actually is
true your text becomes much more
readable if you use black or this also
on the flip side could work I guess it
just works for black and gray I was
trying to think of other color
is where this might also be the case but
I think it's just black and gray that
the Trent black with some transparency
is better than just using the hex color
for gray so I'm actually going to switch
that I thought I had switched that
already in like my main CSS file and I
edited the materialized file but I guess
I didn't maybe I did it on a different
project and just didn't carry it over so
let me fix that now I'll show you let me
this is it with a materialize and input
field label let's change this I kind of
don't want to I kind of don't want to
edit the materialize file directly
because then if I update the version
it's going to overwrite all my changes
so I'm going to add this to my own like
CSS file and actually let me just let me
copy all of this because that'll be
easier and I can just take out the stuff
that I don't need and then just kind of
override what's happening here I'm sure
there's other places where where this is
happening as well so they're also doing
it here so let me change that right now
and my CSS is a bit of a mess right now
I've been kind of slowly working to move
a lot of it into the components but as
you can see I still have a lot here I
could probably get rid of some of it
because I've already moved it over but
for now I don't know I'm just going to
put this at the bottom because I don't
want to take a lot of time to think
about my structure right in the middle
of the live stream so I'm just going to
copy that
or I paste it and all we really need is
that first part and also if you saw in
the in dev tools it was like this for
all the labels so I'm going to go ahead
and just put use this as well so we may
not even use this for anything else on
the site but in case we do that works
works now so the hot module reloading
doesn't work with like a separate CSS
file so those changes require a manual
refresh at least for the way I have
everything set up I'm sure you could
probably use something like live reload
or something like that I know you you
there's a way you can use you can use
gulp with web pack and have it all work
but for this site I did not set it up
let me restart my my dev server
so normally in case you haven't seen
this happen to me before it happens
frequently normally you shouldn't have
to restart your server and I've never
had this happen on another site where
I've been building with react and next
for some reason I don't know what I did
but I've messed something up and it
requires me to frequently restart so I'm
not blaming next for this I'm sure it
was something that I did but just so you
know that's not normally supposed to
happen all right I'm going to go back
and check the live chat because I never
did get around to figuring out where we
should put this thing also we can't
forget to change this color alright so
down downloaded said the search icon
should not move it rohan says it should
be fixed also be nice if you moved it to
the right put it on the right
keep search fire text but it should be
persistent all right so it looks like it
is unanimous it is unanimous that the
search icon should be over here and it
should not move actually I like that
idea and I think if it turns out that
the key up event doesn't register for
the virtual keyboard on a mobile device
then I'm going to make it so that when
you click on this icon it runs the
search as well and then that way we'll
cover that so I think there's there's
definitely value in having this at the
end that's actually what I've done when
I've put in search bars and other sites
that I've done I usually do put it over
here so yeah those Cronus's looks bad
honestly I appreciate your honesty and I
agree on TK Tran says I think mm6 look
better so if 50% look better okay thanks
for that would it I don't know what do
you think do you think 50% look better
obviously if I do that in the drop-down
at some point it's going to look better
to have it you know half in half I'm
sure
okay robot villa icon should be a bit
bigger and great yeah okay bigger as
well I was definitely going to do the
gray um I would make it bigger as well
bill says Oh a follow-up and Twitter
chat more detail but my main issue had
been when get initial cross fires from
client side I was getting mixed content
errors no SSL and WordPress site okay
all right so bill was responding to my
earlier question thanks for responding
and thanks for following up with that so
yeah I was super interested in that so
I'll talk talk to you more about that on
Twitter wall Hodge agrees with robot
villa okay bill says he he left the like
the API logic out of the actual like
components and it kept keep the
front-end cleaner and more reusable
actually I like that idea
okay Patrick is link something on
stackoverflow about the input so let's
check that out really quickly I'm
assuming this is about the like the
mobile the key up thing so let's check
this out because if if we can get an
answer for this right now then then we
can actually fix it make sure it works
on mobile the way we need it to so i've
searched it on my on my other screen you
all I'm sure know about Stack Overflow
works so I don't think I need to show it
[Music]
nice ok so basically the answer is now
that I'm looking at this I'm pretty sure
this is the same Stack Overflow article
I looked up the last time I build a site
like this and I just had totally
forgotten so I am going to bring this
over just to show you all we basically
we have this key up and input okay so
the the key thing is the input input
works both on desktop and mobile that
also this is the other answer it didn't
get I'm not sure why this didn't get
selected either in my food this is
actually this is for jQuery but I'm
assuming there's probably a react
equivalent to this so what it will test
that out although I wish I had maybe I
can do it oh I'll do like a simulator
for an iPhone and test it usually when I
when I'm not building and reacted I'm
building like a static site I use I have
everything set up with gulp and it's
like is it library load or browser watch
or something and it actually gives you
an IP that you can look at on your phone
while you're developing it which is
really cool but I don't
that's not how web pack is set up it
probably can do it I just don't know how
okay Julio says sorry for the question
but I'm interested to know if jesse is a
designer with a programming skill or is
a programmer with design skills good
question I would consider myself to be a
programmer with some design skills so if
you've watched my videos and disagree
feel free to say something but I do have
a lot of opinions about how design
should look and I'm very concerned about
how things should look but I don't and I
consider myself a designer at all but I
was a where I work there are no web
designers that work with me so I do have
to do that job as well my title is
front-end developer but I imagine I
probably do a lot more design than a
front-end developer would would normally
have to do if they're working you know
kind of with a proper team where they
had a you know somebody doing back-end
somebody doing design and all that so
all right let's get back to this let's
let's move this over here and make it
the same color as our text here so let's
do the color first because that's the
easiest thing we can just grab this
color and let's put it oh yeah
resources I wonder if the Phil I don't
know I'm just going to try this but I
don't know if it'll work I don't know if
you can pass a color in like this into
this Phil or not but it's worth a shot
alright awesome that works good to know
and now we're going to move this over to
bait we're going to have to move the
code around because everything is inside
this label is going to move so the
easiest way to make that stop moving is
just to move it outside of the label and
now we need to open and get it off
where we're going to put this so we want
it still in the input but outside of the
label let's put it here and see how it
goes
oops I key normally when I work I have
things in like different views I've just
done it like this so it's easier to
actually they meet let me do this since
I keep doing this anyway on accident
shoot I put it dumb mmm actually that
might work yeah that will probably work
right there I'll just have to do some
positioning so I haven't done any real
like CSS work in a while so this will be
nice let me shoot as soon as I made this
fullscreen now I have a reason to make
it half screen again so let's make it
half screen and bring this in because I
want you all to be able to see what I'm
doing in dev tools I'll have to make dev
tools a bit bigger so you can see so
we'll keep this screen pretty small and
then so we have a little bit more space
here all right so here's our SVG we want
to position this here so let's see
oops position:absolute so I'm going to a
position:absolute and let's go left
eight pixels now I mean sorry right
eight pixels 16 let's see how 16 it
looks and then we needed to come down
from the top
so let's guess 10 pixels nope
I needed some more done more I also want
to make this bigger as well so I should
probably change the size before I settle
on this so let's just see what will
happen if let's go with oops I'm just
going to do auto ok so check that out in
case you're not really used to doing CSS
stuff notice when I put the width
nothing happened until I set height to
auto let's see
I think that that looks all right there
I want it to be I don't want it to be
too small because it needs I guess I
don't know I still don't know whether
I'm going to make it like tap a bull for
a search so um but in case I do I want
it to be big enough so that's reasonable
to tap it but if it's too huge so it's
just not going to fit you know we don't
really have large font going on right
now so needed to fit let me know if you
think that's too big and now if you see
we do this and it stays still all right
so now I'm just going to move this to my
other screen so I can see it when I put
this over on my SVG I could probably get
rid of these so since I've already set
the width and height with the style okay
and I think I'm already at three o'clock
so I don't want to go we talked
yesterday is saying it would be better
to keep the streams to like an hour or
less so this will probably be the the
last thing I do before I go back to the
questions so seems like I didn't get a
whole lot done but I did find some
things that I didn't even expect to be
doing and changed it so got some some
things done but just things I didn't
think I would even have to do so I kind
of don't want to put this right here so
because this is so I said before that I
usually like to put it in line if it's
not really a lot but if it's a lot of
attributes that I have to add or you
know a lot of CSS I don't like to add it
in here because it just gets huge so I'm
gonna go down here I only have input so
we should be able to get this if I just
go to input field SVG that should be
good that's
should cover us in case we put another
SVG on the page somewhere and let's go
to
looks like I never closed that out so
let's close that out right yeah yeah I
never closed that up
okay
and now I'm going to add input field SVG
and let's copy all our Styles over the
other good thing about this is I can
just copy them over exactly as they were
because I can write it just plain CSS
inside of this in case you're not sure
what's going on here like let's just
take a look we have a style tag we've
added this JSX which tells it like hey
so this is not a normal style tag
something's going to happen in here and
now we have our curly brackets so if you
remember from earlier and react
you see these curly brackets that means
okay we're going to do JavaScript now
now it might get confusing for you if
you're not familiar with template
literals because this all doesn't look
like JavaScript right at CSS so what
we've done in here is we used a template
literal when you see one of these in
JavaScript this is a newer type of thing
it's es6 or yes 2015 everything within
this template literal basically is
considered a string there there's really
easy ways to put JavaScript in so if I
went like this you can see like it's
JavaScript so just to show you like I'm
getting a different syntax highlighting
when I do stuff like so anyway that
would be JavaScript in there and I could
put it right in here right in the string
I don't have to put plus signs or
anything so that's what's going on here
so it looks crazy at first if you think
about it makes sense like we're dropping
into JavaScript and we're putting
everything basically as a string but
since we're using the template literal
string we can put you know Speight all
the spaces have it on multiple lines and
it all just works and then because we
have this JSX and the style tag behind
the scenes this is all getting added in
to these elements so when it actually
comes out on the other end I'll save
this and we'll see we'll see what's
going on here let me bring in let me
bring in dev tools
right so now this is that same SVG but
beforehand let me get rid of this stuff
because this is what we typed in dev
tools so we don't you know we're getting
rid of all that and we can see like now
we have this data
- JSX and we just have this this long
number okay so it's giving this its own
unique unique number and then on this
side here we can see we have input field
and then this data JSX number right for
our input field which is here and then
it's saying you know any SVG's within
that input field that have this number
get all this so you can see it's very
specific when it does that it's
definitely not going to mix it up and
put something else in there I mean look
how many digits are in this number like
that's going to cover all your elements
for sure and that's how it works so
pretty I don't know I think that's
pretty cool that you know it kind of
automatically does all that for you and
as we can see just just so that you know
it's working
all right see we have all the styles
that we want and you already saw that I
I took these styles off so the ones we
did in dev tools so this is working just
like we wanted it to work um the only
other thing that we wanted to change was
the color and so let me let me hover
this I know it's not that the input
needs to be hovered right or focus
that's what it needs to be focus okay so
focus a focus color here we need to
change these and we need to change we
need to change the label color as well
so
I guess I'll just copy this this
there's actually a place if I was using
the SAS version of materialized you can
download SAS materializes with the SAS
version of the files all split out or
the CSS version since I don't have like
a SAS compiler running right now I just
went with a straight CSS version but in
the SAS version there's actually a
variable that can set this color this is
the secondary color variable and then I
would only have to change it once and it
would work but that's not unfortunately
that's not how I had it set up so I will
have to change this in a few places and
let me do that in my I'm going to
actually do this in the CSS because
where it's that I thought I had my CSS
running I must have closed no yeah I did
there we go
I'm gonna do it in here and look well I
guess I got to decide on a color huh
let's decide on a color mmm do we want
red I really don't want red that usually
signifies like you know hey there's an
error what other color we're using how
about this I better use the same color
I'm using for this this icon we'll see
how it looks I don't really have the
main colors on the site are really just
red black and white and this is the only
alternate color that I think I'm using
on the whole site this is this is
actually in the university's official
color palettes this is the only color
the only time we're using university
colors on this whole site is for this
color
okay so let's throw this in
and so I haven't been paying attention a
live chat just because I know we were
running out of time and I really want to
do at least have a finished task for
this video
oops oh I got a got a refresh it okay so
you can see here's the color I didn't
change it for that yet we can do that
now
oops I'm at I have my deaf schools open
here so I'm trying to get to this
section in fufu focus and label there we
go alright so I'm gonna copy this and
all I was doing on the other screen was
basically the exact same thing I just
did with this I just found this code in
dev tools and copied and pasted it so if
we refresh that should be working as
well yep and that works oh I don't know
that I love that color but I'm not sure
if I have another color that I'm using
now on the page which would be
appropriate other than black I don't
really want to go with black so there we
go
Banting basically accomplished
everything that we wanted to the only
thing I might do is I don't we had some
some mixed opinions about the length of
this line so maybe I'll move it back
I'll see what I think yeah but that's it
I mean style wise that's that's good to
go
performance wise there were some oops
there's some optimizations that I I
wanted to make but they're not like
critical I don't I don't absolutely have
to do them before this goes live all
right let me check the live chat now
sorry I've been neglecting it for so
long but let me try to figure out where
I left off at I'm sure there's a lot of
good suggestions that I was missing
along the way
okay so we had a suggestion
downloader and said you could try to
leave the current size of search input
so seventy-five percent but then Center
it I'll think about that
okay Julio your title is I didn't hear
that sorry I didn't see that that remark
so if you're still watching because I
was a little while ago that you said
that my title is front-end developer so
that's two fish I'm a front-end
developer for university so that's what
it says on the plaque outside my door
Rowland says if you're connected to the
same network and don't have devices
isolated you can just connect to your
Pete local your PC's loco IP and the
port to view it on mobile okay off to
try that good to know
do nee I'm not sure to pronounce that so
sorry if I did it wrong it's do di oh
and why it says hey Jesse my company I'm
interning for just put me on to free
code camp after completing code Academy
and I love programming keep up the good
work
Oh awesome thank you for for the
positive feedback there I really
appreciate that and you know good luck
with with all your your endeavors on
code Academy or and in free code camp so
looks like you say you completed code
Academy so awesome keep up the good work
okay downloading it has offered some
advice to vertically centering on the
the icon actually I kind of think um I
think it looks okay like that I don't
think I'm going to need a vertically
centered after we made it
that comment might have came like before
I got it all positioned so I'm okay with
it just being kind of statically just
centered here so thank you for the for
the suggestion though roll on suggests
24 pixels I'm assuming that means this
icon 24 pixels may I'll play with that a
little bit later on I'm not going to go
back to it now I'm just going to do
handle these questions but I will I'm
like I'm kind of thinking this is just
like slightly too big yeah I don't know
I get the feeling like like I said I'm
not really a designer so I couldn't
explain to you like reasoning behind
this but to me like just my my gut says
it's just a little too big
Francesca says looks good I love that
name Francesca I got a cousin named
Francesca so often name John says does
Pug work and react I love pug okay yep I
like pub - I well I worked with bugs
sometimes back when it used to be called
Jade and then they got like threatened
to be sued by some other company that
evidently has a copyright for the word
Jade which is crazy because like come on
Jade is like should not be a
copyrightable word it's so legit you
know it's like a very common word you
know anyway um so they had to change the
name to pug I don't really know if pug
works in react so sorry if anybody else
knows you know please please let John
know if if pug works with react
bill says in in regard to being able to
check out dev site on your mobile phone
check out and rock that's ng are okay to
be able to forward your localhost beyond
your network oh you know what I'm like I
feel like a really big idiot right now
because on a previous livestream I
actually demonstrated how to view your
dev site on your phone and I just
totally forgot about it so if you can
connect like I have I have the Google
like pixel phone so it takes a USBC
chord but I think pretty much any phone
now you could get a cord that can
connect it to your computer right so you
connect it to your computer
and you open up dev tools and let me
just bring this over just just to show
you like if we go to remote devices I
don't have it connected right now
because the spot where my cord reaches
is right where my mic is and I'll have a
lot of static like I had a few live
streams ago because of my phone so
basically if you would plug this in you
would see your device right here and you
could do some like debugging right here
on your device but also you can pork
forward so I could forward I actually
already doing it I already added the
port forwarding so I plug this in I say
localhost 3000 is now going to be
localhost 8080 on my phone I type in
localhost 8080 on my phone at wall is
plugged in and I can see it so my brain
just was like totally not working at
that point but thanks for all the other
suggestions for everybody that suggested
in case for some reason this is not
going to work for you or maybe like you
have other people that aren't able to
actually plug in to your computer but on
your network then you know you might
want to set it up in some other way
Roland says a tad smaller and a bit
more to the left so it could go a bit
more to yeah you're right a bit more
left yeah you know what I'm actually
going to do to is uh I know that I think
on some of google sites they have a
similar set up with the search icon here
I'm going to check it out since I am
going by material design guidelines
sometimes I do like to look like okay
well how did Google implement this and
so I'll check out one of those sites
just to give me some visual reference
for how they interpreted the material
design guidelines in their own sites so
that's if you like material design you
want to use it I recommend doing that
like check out Google Sites that use
material design and just just get ideas
because documentation doesn't cover
every use case possible sometimes it's
nice to see how it's been adapted John
says in sass to in the JavaScript style
strings and react as far as I know you
can't use sax sass in the JavaScript
style string so let me go back to this
just to give some reference to what
we're talking about
so this in JSX
you can check out there there's actually
this is on github um something where the
repo is a camera with the repo skull but
basically on my other screen I'm just
going to look it up real quick at this
time I don't think they're support for
sass in here but I have seen I don't
maybe it was in a github issue or
something I've seen a discussion about
enabling something like that inside of
here but I don't think it's enabled
right now not to say it's not possible
but I just haven't seen it done and
here's the github repo for that it's
styled JSX
so it's the same people that do next so
site is the
next sew style look up style dat JSX and
this will let you know basically what it
can and can't do and like I think maybe
there was one of the issues for this did
bring up that aspect so I would really
actually like to use sass as well or at
least some of the feet even if it
couldn't implement all of some of the
features would be nice Francesca says
the search icon is a functional icon
element so visibility is key we want to
help our users at all times in a way
they don't have to think about what they
have to do don't make me think principle
alright good good advice bill says John
is supporting next yes I believe style
JSX is what they talk about in the docs
all right sir
bill bill answered it before I even did
so John says so so sass is possible cool
thing I don't really know so once again
I I don't really know for sure such as
possible I think it is it's just not
been implemented so I'm sure they might
be open you know to a pull request to
try to implement alright getting towards
the end of the of the live chat comments
so just in case you're still sticking
around and you're not really worried
about the live chat I'm not going to do
any more coding so if you want to take
off now you know feel free thanks for
watching
otherwise if you have any more questions
I'm getting towards the end so get your
questions in now before I wrap things up
and where you could direct message me on
Twitter or you could put it in the
comments to this video if you're
watching the recording put it in the
comments or message me on Twitter or
whatever other social media you prefer
I've actually had people email me things
too so I'm not opposed to that if you
find my phone number and call me though
I probably won't answer but if you leave
a message I'll listen to it
Oh Sebastian's here
okay so Sebastian is a regular viewer
here
also has given me some great tips on
like sending me error screenshots of
errors he's gotten on my site which has
been super helpful so Sebastian
basically you just miss me working on
this the search input just styling it so
I mean that's all at the beginning I
talked a little bit about adding images
into these cards and I've done that on
another branch but that's pretty much it
probably doing too much talking and not
enough coding to be honest with you but
Colonel Colonel zoom or I guess but
that's with an X and not as he says I'm
having trouble understanding the grid
layout and how to place things like a
line of text next to images or or other
text if you are using materialized with
the columns and rows let me check out
the repo okay so you'll be able to see
in obviously the materialized
documentation might have some
explanation but if you want like real
world examples check out my repo the
link is in the description or pretty
much all of all of my projects for the
last on a year or so have been using
materialized so they all have examples
but just to show you quickly how this
works let me show you a section that
does put images next to text just to
give you an idea courses alright so in
courses I do so subsection down the ball
I know I have some down the bottom this
this is a mess I can't wait to move this
all this junk out into WordPress and
just pull that in so here I have
basically I have a section alright which
you don't really need the section and I
have a container and this is the
container is basically just for adding
like padding on the sides and I've
modified this a bit because I didn't I
didn't like the normal
Tanner padding like how wide it was so I
added this class wide container that it
makes it a little bit wider so that's
that's my class this is comes with
materialized and now what we have in
here is a row so this is how you you get
the columns and everything to work so
basically you have a row you usually
don't have a row on its own it's usually
wrapped in a container or at least a
section but so you have your row and
then within your row you have columns
okay so the first column I have is on
small screens it takes up the whole
space and on medium sized screens which
is anything over 600 pixels you have it
takes up half the space because half of
there's only 12 columns half of 12 is 6
right so this this is something I added
that's a that's custom it basically just
changes the order of the image and the
text on a mobile so that I always have
the image on the top and the text below
and then on a big screen there they're
staggered so one section has image and
text like text first image second the
other section has image first Exide
second so you won't have this by default
but if you see it and look at my code
that that's what it's doing so this is
the first section and then this is the
second section and if your screen is
larger than 600 pixels they will show up
one right after the other so the text
will show up on the right-hand side and
on the left hand side will be the image
and they'll both take up half the screen
but then if you have a small screen the
text well normally what would happen is
whatever you put first would be on top
and what you put second would be on the
bottom both taking up the full width in
this case I have changed the order be
like I just explained that I wanted
consistency when people are scrolling on
mobile that's how the basic columns work
in materialise if you wanted to have
like this be 75% width and this be 25% I
could change this m6 to m9 and change
this m6 to m3 and that would give me
that in you know is
as what you have here between these two
add up to 12
no more than 12 then you're good and and
they'll be side by side so hopefully
that answered your question let me know
if it didn't um me or you know send me a
direct message or something and I could
explain it in more depth maybe I'll do a
video on stuff like this since I use
materialised frequently maybe I could do
a little video just on materialized okay
Sebastian says centered it looks kind of
weird like that alright so let me bring
this back up since we're talking about
this okay so the search thing you think
centered it looks weird like that okay
so I'm definitely going to do something
with this because a lot of people saying
basically do something with it either
Center it or take it back to half or do
so something is going to happen with
that
Franchesca said thank you I like your
name also Jesse thanks um James says as
a software tester I have to agree the
search is a bit large okay awesome yeah
so that will definitely shrink up I'm
not going to shrink it up too much but
maybe like four pixels somewhere around
there I'll see how it looks
Thor a Thor's here Thor says hey hey
Thor um actually now that Thor's here
this reminds me I have a question for
you all so I have a major project that's
coming up so I did mention I had
meetings this morning so basically like
my work life for the next year is all
booked up at as far as at prints at
Franciscan University where I work is
concerned so I guess that's good because
I'll know what's coming but I do have a
huge project that's on the horizon and
maybe even though this year that might
be next year but what I need to happen
at least what I would hope was happen I
database that is um feeding data to a
site that's running a content management
system called Ektron okay
not my choice to use Ektron that's I
inherited it when I started working here
I want to move the content over to
WordPress since we're already using
WordPress for a lot of our content it
would be easy to be able to teach like
our student workers to use WordPress and
then they could know how to update all
the content so the idea is is it
possible is there some way and how hard
would it be to move the data out of that
Ektron database and then move it into
another database that WordPress is going
to use but move it in such a way that it
will be in the it will be structured in
the normal WordPress way so WordPress
will understand it I don't know very
much at all about databases so I don't
know if what I'm describing even make
sense to do if you have some experience
and you're watching this either live
right now or later on recording please
let me know direct message me or put in
the comments or something because I've
been it will save a lot of time and
money if we can do that and to be honest
with you like I think I could probably
talk the you know my bosses into you
know paying someone to do it so if you
know how to do that and you're
interested you know let me know also
actually I just remembered this from my
meeting I had a meeting yesterday
morning as well and I was given an award
for this website that I'm working on
right now it's a spirit award so it's
not like a really big deal thing but
it's cool you get like a fifty dollar
award and a piece of papers describing
what a good job you did so that was cool
it's nice to be recognized for doing a
good job it was actually my boss
nominated me for it so that was pretty
cool all right back to the to the live
chat questions I want to get through
these yeah oh man I've already gone an
hour and a half I really need to I
needed like set a long
and timers to work on getting my
livestream times down to something more
manageable that's not as intimidating to
watch the recordings so hopefully I
don't forget over the weekend and I
remembered it really set some sets of
timers and quit you know really forced
myself to stop at some point
[Music]
Rohan says yeah I usually use Chrome
console using USB to my experiment I
cable Google has some space between end
of icon and end of month okay so those
are two different different thoughts I
ran them together so he said Google has
some space between of icon and of line
okay that's why what I thought that's
why I did it like that if you know like
there's a little bit of space because
like I said it's been somewhat recently
at least recent enough for me to
remember that I did a very similar input
to this on a site and I remember looking
it up and the Google had some space so
that's why I added the space so I'll
double check though and maybe get try to
make it as close as possible since I'd
like to stick to material design as much
as I can for consistency's sake across
all of my sites and for the users so
that you know a lot of people were
exposed to material design so if I use
those same you know design patterns I
think there's an increased chance of a
user automatically knowing what to do
because they're familiar with it I like
that idea I think yeah it's cool
sometimes to experiment and make an
amazing-looking site but sometimes when
you do that users have no idea like if
you look at like the top design sites
that win the awards they look amazing
and they do cool things but a lot of
times at least me when I go to them I
have no idea how to use them at first so
that's not what I want for this site you
know maybe I just messing around on the
side I could do crazy things but that's
one of the reasons why I just stick with
material design and don't really branch
off and I just I modify it when I have
to you know when there's not some
explicit direction I'm doing some type
of component that's not mentioned in the
docs but
[Music]
anyway I don't I don't even know I think
I feel like I went off on a tangent
there some kid back to the logit patrick
said by the way what I said about SAS
and next is wrong it looks like they are
supporting script JSX type equals text
slash SAS but I'm not sure how far the
support has come yet all right awesome
Patrick good to know so a question
earlier I think I think John had the
question earlier I don't know if he's
still in the live chat but yeah it looks
like he's still in there so it looks
like maybe SAS support is on the way or
maybe like somewhat supported so that's
really good to know I might check that
out and try to use it because I I like
to use SAS when I can on on projects
okay someone mentioned the the IRC
channel in case you you haven't heard
there's an IRC channel now like to
continue this discussion a live chat
later on it's like hash tag FCC Jesse
and that's running at what is it free
node so I don't really know very much at
all about IRC so I can't really help you
get things set up I'm just learning with
the help of some people like Rohan and
Thor here that are in the live chat and
so I try to log in as much as I can I
keep getting logged out all the time
though I'm not seeing things so I just
need to do a little bit more research
and figure out how to best use IRC but
but if I'm in there and you have
questions I'll do my best to answer them
as well or the other people in there
actually really knowledgeable more
knowledgeable than me and they can help
you as well
[Music]
John says thanks for the info on sass
Jessie and Patrick you are you're
welcome
Patrick really did the work and found
the right answer so I appreciate that
Patrick and your ass note is the only
way to do server-side rendering what do
you do when having another language on
the back end row unanswered you could do
server-side rendering in any language
yeah that's my understanding too is that
you you can do I mean if you think about
it like a regular like WordPress site
uses PHP and it renders using PHP on the
server-side right so the same way with
like if you're using like dotnet
framework stuff you know everything it
gets rendered there on the server side
so that's actually like the traditional
way of doing websites the benefit to
using node and react at least the way I
am is that I render the first load is
rendered server-side so it's a nice fast
first load it's just like a static HTML
page gets sent and search engines can
see that so that's the main reason but
then after that first load all the
additional routes so when I click on an
internal link that is actually all done
client-side so you have the best of both
word world so you have the routing
without a page refresh that's super fast
on the client-side but then you also get
the SEO benefits and the quick loading
benefits of that so that's why I do it
it's I don't maybe it could be done to
where you don't have to use node and you
could I don't know can you run react
with other stuff on the backend and do
it kind of like this I I don't know
enough about it to know like if I could
run react and render react with PHP I
don't really know but you can definitely
do it with other languages and that
seems to be we had some other people
give the same answer there in the in the
latch at kernel says and I do this
within the same row yes you do so he's
responded to when I was demonstrating
the the column sorry I'm late with that
there's there's a delay on the video so
it's it's not exactly real time when I
can respond to you like what you're
seeing also I you know I was answering
some other questions too so so if if
you're whatever you are seeing is
actually like what I just said like a
minute ago so that's why I'm it might be
a little off as to when I'm explaining
things or answering questions
inside the matrix says I like that name
says sorry I'm new is WordPress calm or
org so work if you're not familiar
WordPress there's wordpress.com and
wordpress.org one is like you can go
there and just get a site up and running
and like it's WordPress takes care of
all the hosting and everything like that
and you just do your blogging and it has
limited functionality in terms of what
plugins and customizations you can do
the other one is you can download the
entire CMS onto your server for free and
set it up and run it however you want
and customize it however you want I
can't remember what it I think the self
hosted version is dot org and the.com is
the version that they host so correct me
if I'm wrong with that but that's the
and I'm not even sure if that answers
your question right way inside the
matrix but hopefully it does
Rowan says I don't know about how both
CMS handle databases but it can be done
oh ok so this is in response to my
question about databases and and for
also had a response earlier and it I
just now realized it was in response to
that says if both systems have an API it
would probably work ok I'll have to have
to look into that so let's say one
system doesn't have any like so the
WordPress API I already know how to
input data with the WordPress API so I
didn't even think about that but that's
that's doable I don't know if the other
database has an API I was reading the
documentation and it said there was some
sort of API but after look like
comparing the documentation of how it's
supposed to be implemented and how this
CMS was actually implemented I'm
referring to the Ektron CMS that I was
talking about earlier it seems like
there were some things that were
recommended in the documentation that
weren't implemented and I don't know for
sure because this was done before I was
here a lot of the work was done by an
outside company and some of the work was
done by an employee who's no longer
here so I'm really like having to figure
things out on my own
and just like go through the code and
just try to figure out what happened so
would it be possible then and I'm sure
it probably is like to build my own API
that pulls from that database if if
there's not one already maybe that's
maybe that is is the the real answer to
that
all right Thor says Sebastian says you
could get the data from the database and
post it to WP Thor thinks that's
probably not a good idea
Rohan says database level is easy but
not a great idea all right thanks for
that because I was thinking originally
just on the database level but I hadn't
even considered the API that seems more
doable for me because I'm familiar with
working with api's but a lot more so
than I'm familiar with working straight
with the database so this is like really
really helpful for me
okay so Thor has clarified the dot-com
is the hosted instances and the.org is
when you host it yourself so I think I
had it backwards okay honestly if you
just type in with one or the other
you'll find out really quickly which one
is which oh okay
rowan said congratulations that's
amazing and i'm like wait what's amazing
what I miss and that must have been when
I was talking about getting the award
it's called a spirit award so yeah I
mean it's not like the spirit it's a
pretty common thing a lot of employees
do get it but like I've been here for
almost two years
and I've only gotten it once before so
um yeah so I mean I was happy I mean any
little thing if showing appreciation is
you know that's awesome when that
happens and not that my boss didn't
already let me know that he appreciated
it but yeah the award was nice and the
extra 50 bucks is nice
considering all the extra work I put in
there it's not much compared to that but
it's still cool you know lets me know
that yeah
my boss does care let's see Francesca
says CMS to CMS comm can migrate extra
onto WordPress wait are you serious
Francesca you might be my favorite
person of the day if that if that can
work because I never heard that so I am
definitely going to check that out if
there's like a system that already does
this then like on you have no idea like
literally the main thing stopping me
from completely redoing our main
university sites it's Franciscan ddu
right now the site runs on like X Ron
which is super old and it's really hard
for people to update the content and it
loads all this stuff all the time
and I've been trying to go through it
and just like manually edit templates
and things to make it faster but it's
just like it takes a long time to
accomplish like little things so I want
to totally redo it and do it like I did
this see I cite the catechetical
Institute site with react and the
backend be WordPress and make it just
really fast so the one thing stopping me
from doing that was the idea of who is
going to move all this content there
well over 3,000 pages to this site
there's a ton of content so we were
thinking like we're going to have to
hire like some student workers and pay
them you know you know have them work a
ton of hours to do this and I'm not
thrilled about the idea of people
copying and copying and pasting content
so anyway so thank you very much
Francesca I just went to this site so
here's the site so this actually looks
really cool I'm definitely going to
check out this site and this is not an
official endorsement of the site I
haven't even looked at their page yet so
just so you know uh
I always feel like I need to give a
disclaimer when I talk about some paid
service like like I'm not making money
off of this and I'm not officially
endorsing it and that's it I actually
don't make money off of anything if
anybody ever wants to use an affiliate
link from me because like you appreciate
what I'm doing and when I help me out
then that's cool let me know but
otherwise I'm not going to push that
kind of thing let's see does someone use
typo3 typo3 I don't I don't use it I've
actually never heard of it so Andrew
asked that John says he does or John
says he's here alright cool cuz I
thought Sean if he was still here so I
just wanted you to hear some of the
answers to the stuff you would ask
Rowland says try IRC cloud for Android
awesome I will do that I'll show to
download that app rohan says I had a
complicated setup previously but now I
just moved to using IRC cloud on Android
suite that would actually be good and
then I could get the messages anywhere
and I don't have to be at a computer I
tried to use um some like command line
client and I wasn't exactly sure I must
want to set it up right because it
wasn't working correctly for me I didn't
really have time to read the
documentation thoroughly so the law also
says for Android atomic is awesome for
IRC Oh Sebastian says what app to use
for the IRC for Windows Thor says hex
chat is good
once again I'm not like I haven't used
any of these things so I don't know I'm
just reading out the live chat for those
of you who are going to be watching this
later on so that you can you can get the
benefit of the live chat without
actually being here because correct me
if I'm wrong but you can't see the live
chat on the recording videos right if
I'm wrong about that then I may be
wasting my time by reading all these
but I'm pretty sure you can all right
almost to the end here to probably wrap
this up and maybe like let five minutes
or less I our SSI is mentioned here
Roland mentions that and that one's for
Linux okay inside the matrix said yes
that answered my question
awesome glad glad I could could help out
there Berlin says it's free with
donation so I our SSI for Linux free
with donation and he says it's also
available for Mac - he thinks Thor said
is for Linux he prefers WeChat that's
actually I think we chat might be the
one that I tried to download and use I
got it all loaded and I started it up
and everything and then I kind of hit a
wall and couldn't get it to work any
further than that says not they're not
available for Windows though for says I
guess CMS - CMS is just people doing it
but not sure like the people are doing
it for you James says you're correct
okay so that's actually somebody doing
it I'm actually I'm cool with that like
I said I'm it's definitely worthwhile to
pay for this to be done because
otherwise it's going to cost a lot of
money either way I think unless unless I
level up my skills and figure out how to
how to migrate it in a way that's really
easy
which I'm not opposed to I like learning
new things I just enough confident that
I can do it in a way that it would be
efficient and really work correctly I
much rather have somebody who has a lot
of experience do that because if
something would happen that content it
would be it would be disastrous it's
quite a bit of calm
yes Sebastian says I don't think it's
copy and paste by humans so oh okay
Sebastian said it says 15-minute
migration on average we're talking about
the site CMS the CMS comm that Francesca
had recommended for migrating databases
from one CMS to the other
it says 15-minute migration on average
full-scale CMS in about 15 minutes yeah
actually that makes me thank it um there
must there's got to be some automated
stuff going on somewhere along the way
right I mean I'm sure there are people
that are it's not like you click a
button and entered info and
automatically happens but anyway off to
check that out a little bit more so like
I said that's not a project that's
actually not one of the projects that I
that we had talked about in our meeting
earlier today for the upcoming year but
it is a project that I think is like
within the next two years it it should
have I think it should happen in my
opinion the most important project is
the main site project because that gets
like by far the most traffic but that's
not the opinion of people higher up so
not can probably not going to be able to
work on that right now
umberto says I make buttons that you
click once in a day's worth of work is
done that that is awesome that is a good
a good skill alright that's the end of
the live chat so I'm going to wrap this
up because this ended up being nearly a
two-hour video despite my intentions so
today's Friday right so yeah today is
Friday so I will be back on Monday and
Monday will be the last week before I'm
on vacation so the week after I'll be on
vacation and I don't know if I'll be
able to stream or not depends on the
internet and on like what's going on
I should probably spend take a little
break on vacation but we'll see I mean
maybe it'll be like really rainy I'm
going to the beach so maybe it'll be
rainy and I'll be inside and maybe I'll
do a stream or something so alright yeah
hey have a great weekend everybody
saying bye in the live stream so I
really appreciate everyone watching and
all the great questions and the great
advice and yeah so I think we're
starting to develop like a nice little
community that's helping each other here
and I think that's really awesome so a
lot of a lot of very knowledgeable
people are contributing to make this
stream so much better than it could be
if it was just me and I really
appreciate that
hey you you're welcome thanks for
watching so I'm going to I'm going to
wrap this up and I'm going to try to
write down all the stuff suggestions
that you guys gave so I don't forget it
over the weekend and yeah so thanks and
I'll see you on Monday
you